don't the clock that time Gordon tension
away look out here he comes that brings
the crowd to its feet
nice job by Aaron Gordon and a little
treat on Halloween Eve for the fans
[Applause]
the fourth team foul on the Thunder
inbounds report a beautifully executed
side of the bounds play this is a very
good cutting team he will reward them
soaring high above the rim air Gordon
look watched the back screen being sent
and here in Gordon off a terrific pass
from Marco the Mavericks defense again
to the middle and then no help from
Powell on the backside down there but
doesn't see the basketball watch the
ball swing too cheap up top there's the
ball in the air MCW in trouble 8g bails
email right down the middle
oh shoot time to go with it
coming right to you behind
for the jam my goodness air Gordon
lifting upward the game what a pass by a
one do in aichi work in the baseline
just gonna 360 this thing wrong G got to
give it up and you'll get it right back
whoo you never know guys step up and for
one game here and there can certainly
respond volts delivers in sight the
Gordon and the magic are off to a good
start starting to come around
Nikola boots have it's such a big part
of both into the floor for the magic
they get a stop on one end and a slam
dunk by Gordon on the other CW forcing
another turnover by Milwaukee ahead
I can look at the dump by Aaron Gordon
again just kidding helps in transition
and Brook Lopez no shot
10-point game folks the foul Gordon to
Vukovich here's how the magic likes to
run their half-court offense with foutch
making decisions and Gordon soaring high
and ain't nothing runs thick look at the
bugs they could or I could put Jonathan
Gordon takes off
down Corde puts it right on the money
and philadelphia can only stand by and
watched the high-flying
Aaron Jordan
what dimes out here watch Aaron Gordon
this pass is deflected AG just a running
start kind of seen who's kind of running
a team there for a second Ling you take
a look at Tyler hero and say young fella
you can't stop this Aaron Gordon and get
much better than this the up and under
no room
don't up there go get it yourself
15-point lead for the under six
[Applause]
what was McKee thinkin remarkable that
era was able to stretch out and finish
that duck big time dunk by Eric Gordon
Aaron Gordon's Drive here big first step
going right at Noel just not going high
enough there's a steal by folks like
Dell is Gordon running alongside another
assist for marquel folks
Aaron Gordon reverses it in New York
we'll take a timeout to read each other
well look at all the attention and then
hearing Gordon little something extra
for a preview of the dunk contest here
David John Collins fumbles it away
picked up by marquel focus between two
defenders it's just a great job by
marquel another fish Mary Gordon with
the two-handed dunk
[Music]
nature that's directing traffic gives
will support any four notches in Reverse
two-handed times Thank You [ __ ]
practice for the dunk there of good
points in the paint team fourth in the
league in that but there are six scuse
me but that's a lot to do this is a
great job just Aaron off the steel
everybody knows something specials
coming AG does not disappoint
Atlanta takes time out the Hawks lead
cramp Rose with across the magic defense
picked off by Gordon on the drive no
such thing as tired legs with Aaron
Gordon watch this one starting five back
on the floor down by 14 four minutes to
play in the first half
bucho Fitz double-team Gordon cutting to
the basket and a foul on Miami
gets his own miss Hill back in against
Russell and duck it through first field
goal for Aaron gore has good strong hand
love to see him get a full head of steam
downhill Aaron Gordon aye Gomez to wait
too little